definitely men because they get paid
more and they also don't have to deal
with sexual harassment in the streets
and if they want to be shirtless they
also don't have to worry about somebody
looking at them like they're just
throwing themselves out there okay so
since you believe my life is so hard I
have to put a shirt on Wow believe that
would you be willing to switch gender
roles with a
man no because I like being a woman no
well then well then wouldn't that prove
that women women have it easier in
society otherwise women would want to
switch gender roles no that is not true
women don't have it easier we get judged
way more than
men look how stupid she looks with her
boobs out complaining about sexual
harassment you're sexually harassing
every man you walk by by putting your
boobs out you could get a neckline like
this it would be put away